帝王切開は一般的に c セクションと呼ばれ
出産の際母体の腹部と子宮を切開する
外科的な処置です
何らかの帝王切開が計画されます
陣痛開始後異常な状態により膣からの出産が母子にとって安全でないと判断される場合
この処置が必要となります
帝王切開を必要とする的要衝には異常分娩前地帯板
胎児仮死などがあります
第二の頭が産道を通過できないあるいは体の位置が参道に対し垂直であったり
全部が最初に来ているような場合異常分娩になるか
長時間にわたり陣痛が進まないことがあります
全治対バンは胎盤の位置が低く子宮頸部の開きを部分的
または全体的にブロックする場合に起こります
胎盤またはへそのを通過する血流量不足が原因で胎児の生命が急迫に危険に瀕した場合
胎児仮死ば起こりえます
しかしは分娩前に子宮壁から胎盤が剥離したりまたはヘソ脳が圧迫されると起こる可能
性があります
帝王切開を要する可能性のある状況にはこのほか次のような場合があります
たし出産大きな子宮内しよう陰部ヘルペス
または他の間選手をあるいは管理不足の糖尿病や高血圧といった
内科的疾患などです担当医が超音波検査を使って胎児の心臓もモニターし
あなたの胎児を帝王切開で出産するべきかを判断します
帝王切開が必要となると手術の準備に取り掛かります
点滴ラインを挿入していない場合はそれを開始し尿を排出させるためにカテーテルを
暴行に挿入します
手術室に入り麻酔をかけます
ほとんどの場合脊椎麻酔が投与され体の下半身の感覚がなくなります
時に全身麻酔が使用されることもあります
担当医が腹部の石灰を開始します
へそのましたから恥骨の上まで縦に切開するかまたは多くのケースでは恥骨のすぐ上を
垂直に切開します
これはいわゆるべきにカットと呼ばれています
担当医は続いて地球株に2度目のメスを入れます
地球を開けて破水がまだの場合は担当医は妖魔苦悩を割いて胎児を取り出します
腹部の最初の石灰から分娩まで通常は5分程度です
担当医は続いてヘソ脳を留め具で固定して切断したい版を取り出し
地球と腹部をしっかりと縫合します
通常これには約45分かかります
帝王切開後通常23日入院します
入院中は授乳を進められ新生児が眠っている間お休み
なるだけベッドから起き上がるようにします大抵の患者は出産後間もなく新生児の世話
ができますが完全に回復するには
6から8週間かかることもあります傷跡は回復するにつれ薄れていきます